патре цей артилерійський підрозділ
знаходиться за 10 км від росіян на
бахмутському напрямку військові тут
щоденно захищають піхоту і обстрілюють
російські позиції незважаючи на холод і
гризунів їх чути швидше ніж ви зможете
їх побачити миші гризуть усе від пальців
сплячих військових до комп'ютерних
кабелів та все можуть гризти провода і в
Да їм руки руки пальці в епоху старлінки
сучасних технологій бійці все ще чекають
на інновацію щоб перемогти гризунівти
потікали
потікали сури тут завелися здорові Вони
ж безобидны без них с ума зайдм
нормально хоть весело та заважають
працювати не лише миші а й морози
ожеледиця ускладнює логістику тому
доставка боєприпасів відбувається
повільніше сложность тому що морози
погода така техніка ламається і
якби монтувати тоже не вспіваємо
бистроступа
Анка ихня мы таемся их
учто
подальше если погода
хороша А сечас погода
яту только чисто піхоту прикривають що
вони наступають під час літнього наступу
військові змогли просунутися на ці
позиції вони збудували собі нові
бліндажі добре знаючи що від цього
залежатиме їхнє життя ну просування було
Ми стояли не
тут получается Ми там дальше стояли ну
переїхали десь
місяці два-три десь
назад сюди то есть вперед поки щчас
стоїм а там дальше буде видно Ну час
поки оборона тому що вони щчас
наступають і якби ми
питаємося відбить їхні напади якщо
допустим ми робимо на заборону там
три-чори то вони можуть зробити і 10 і
15 Цієї зими Вони захищають свої позиції
від російських військ які намагаються їх
повернути прилетіло неожидано Угу
неприятно було снаряд упаврядо ускочни
получается Возле входа да І воно таке Ну
да сіяние такоїхали сюда все російські
дрони постійно полюють на техніку
оскільки вони і вдень і вночі
знаходяться в небі То цей український
артилерійський підрозділ фактично живе
під землею тоді коли не веде вогонь по
цілях
затримують 20 Вони шукають откуда
выстала откуда де стоять позиция
потом начинає їхня ателе
тають
дм так само і ночю літають якщо ми
работаєм по якось цілі з висоти воно все
видно видно виходи наші і якби дм дим
стоїть посля вистріла якби це все видно
якщо вони нас побачать це уже нам
конечно прийдеться потом по бліндажам
тому що
воничинаютьроні ворогаі я кажуть бійці
Ну
тут в основному що тут зала Орлан нцет
каби ланце так само ізначально вроде би
ланцети зала і орлани були Ну їх не так
багато бу зараз вони можуть отак
пролітає от в
сторону Ну в ту сторону пролітає там
вони по пару літають зали і
орланн Ну вони пролетіли За ними ще
можуть пролетіть Ну то есть за день
Багато їх
може вони так чи кругами там я не знаю
ну питаються виїзкують техніку для того
щоб дати повноцінну відповідь росіянам
треба більше людей і техніки наголошують
військові якщо
брати количество їх і нас то нас дуже
мало як не крути нашій піхоти дуже
мало та і техніки Так же
само у них багато цього всього допустим
если нам дали от 100 одиниць техніці то
це добре У них
допустим 1000 єдиниць техніці у них та
більше чим у нас ми з нашими
ста І держим позиції і продвигаємся
вперед у якби тяжко не було а в них
скільки теці ну і у них ну не
получається если б допустимсну техніку
нам то так я думаю ми б їх давно уже
вигнули отсюда Кілька десятків чоловіків
ховаються разом у землянці вирить їй на
кілька метрів підмерзлою землею
супутниковий інтернет з'єднує їх із
сім'ями буває рідним дзвониш дучці там
як в школі тапа сьогодні субота або
неділя
ну День сурка Якщо ти працюєш Ти тупо не
знаєш який день частина бійців не змогла
звикнути до постійних обстрілів і була
змушена перейти в інші підрозділи людина
до всього може привикнути просто щось
складно
удається хтось боїться
то То понятно що людина не привикна за
чого если вона боїться сильно
цього якби цього всі бояться нує люди
які
сильножзнаєте
[музика]
прям які боялися і ми Їх відправили але
тут не критикують тих хто пішов та
кажуть ідеального солдата не існує і
Ніхто з них не народжений для війни ми ж
тоже невічні
правильно втрати є з усіх
старів сидіти дома і казати там я хворий
або я не народжений для війни немаж
такого що мати родила тебе і каже О все
буде
служити воювати доведеться усім тому
немає сенсу ховатися кажуть військові
адже повномасштабна війна триває вже
майже два роки всьому навчають і ти
будеш вчитися Тому що тут якщо ти не
будеш вчитися то
же тут не прибачають помилок можуть всі
В нас всі хто там там були в одному Розі
приходять інші вчаться дуже
швидко абсолютно Ну ми ж не всі з одним
характером ми всі різні Але всі вчаться
це твоє життящо не будеш вчитися то буде
погано
Це в твоїх інтересах А дехто з них воює
майже 10 років ще з початку АТО в мене
уже багато свят так пройшло це наша
робота захищати
людейр